I organized this conference and we talk
about the return of fascism and and and
all the creeps which are coming up again
and again and again um and we talked
about science and we talked about uh uh
the the the world of the Arts etc etc
etc because there is still this question
how is it possible that quotequote the
highest culture we have had the world of
be over b c go name it and out of this
you got what you showed us how is it
possible and you know how is it possible
that that Europe could commit
suicide and genocide on such a level at
the high time with the best science we
all had planes etc etc
etc in a way it is done you know there's
I mean we live in the afterwards of this
um in a way is spiritual and moral and
and physical self-destruction so we we
are Beyond we're in the ruins of that
we're still a we're still are we can
pretend what we're not but you know but
we are so but why was it never not
possible it was one of Europe's worst
conceits that its culture in some way
elevated itself morally and the
connection
between cult ation artistic cultivation
on the one hand and moral behavior on
the other is a very fraught connection
just as the connection between character
and art is a very very fraud connection
Europe was always guilty of
barbarism always from the Middle Ages
through the early modern period through
the slave trade through the genocide of
the alians through the persecution and
extermination of the Jews to the
treatment of Muslims to the the I mean
Europe has
no Europe's moral
reputation its reput it's cultural
reputation is certainly deserved but
that is not at all the same as its moral
reputation yeah in fact the the tension
that you draw attention to I've always
found it easier to make sense of it by
just
recognizing that this Gloppy gray
structure inside of our head called the
human brain it evolved under pressures
in the African Savannah not to find
truth the brain didn't evolve to find
truth it didn't evolve to find what's
right the brain evolved to survive and
survival and truth and morality are
distinct considerations and in some
sense it's remarkable where the brain
has gotten us like you say Beethoven
Bach Einstein Schrodinger the fact that
we can create great works of art that we
can find great insights of science
that's utterly remarkable but to have
expected that very same brain to have a
universal moral Center that would always
behave in a way that was best for the
group of humanity it's an unrealistic
and obviously an incorrect assumption so
it's not to me particularly surprising
that the brain can do horrific things
unfortunately you see
Western world is as n know very well is
the land of sunset okay our destiny is
fading out always every day of our life
and it's it is true what lion was saying
that uh Western Civilization always
brought along with itself Barbarian not
only with Nazi uh always always but it's
also true that that Western I would say
European civilization if you allowed me
always uh
doubt of itself always criticize its
foundation and I may be wrong but I
think it's the only culture that does
that always so culture and Massacre
always together along our history but
also create criti we we've always been
able of criticize ourself no criticize
our
foundation look for New Foundation for
our old values yeah personally I don't
agree with you on that I think we are
now desperately looking for uh secular
foundation for Transcendent values but
we must be proud of that